hi my name is grace Helbig and I'll be
your substitute gym teacher today
welcome to once-over Wednesday's are
short I went on my tumblr and asked you
guys what did you want to see reviewed
and so many of you said the Justin
Bieber deposition video I have not seen
it yet you want to watch it with me he
did a bad thing
and he got a the wall gave him a gentle
fist in the butt and he then had to go
to the court system and do I'm a great
news anchor um Justin Bieber a
deposition for it's six and a half
minutes
how do you guys sit through my stuff 2.5
million views 10,000 likes and 7000
dislikes not the best ratio March 6 2014
that was five days ago that's it's
what's for dinner when you're a
calculator his skin looks beautiful I'm
so distracted by his beautiful skin you
checked would you please Oh what is it I
gonna show him is it frozen his lips are
so pouty oh he winked at the camera and
my [ __ ] love
I think that lawyer is a fan don't ask
me about maybe you should ask you about
drinking water this is riveting okay to
correct each other political news
reference is asked more about Selena
solidarity bro my question was was huh
sure it's a good question
helpful to professional career it's not
sure a close friend
I sure giving you career advice is this
video sponsored by Usher is this an
interview or deposition of you sir Wow
who has extra sunglasses coz ho that was
Shady
I think I have a new crush and I think
that I'm probably worse for watching
that video dad I don't know